let's say that we've got company a over
here and it takes out a one million
dollar loan
takes out a one million dollar loan it
pays a variable interest rate on that
loan it pays libor
libor plus two percent and libor stands
for london inter-bank offer rate it's
one of the major benchmarks for variable
interest rates and so it pays that to
some lender this is the person who lent
company a the money it pays them a
variable interest rate every period so
for example in period one if libor
if libor is at five percent then in that
period company a will pay seven percent
or
seventy thousand dollars to the lender
in that period in period two if libor
goes let's say libor goes down a little
bit to four percent then company a is
going to pay four plus two which is six
percent or
six percent which is sixty thousand
dollars in interest sixty thousand
dollars in interest let's say that we
have another company company b right
over here it also borrows one million
dollars but it bars it at a fixed rate
let's say it borrows it at a fixed rate
of eight percent
eight percent fixed interest rate so in
each period regardless of what happens
to libor what any other benchmark and so
this is to
probably another lender a different
lender than the person that a barred it
from and it could be a bank or it might
be another company or an investor of
some kind we will call this lunder one
and lender two so regardless of the
period right now company b will pay
eight percent of one million dollars in
each period and that which is about
eighty thousand dollars or exactly
eighty thousand dollars each period
now let's say that neither of these
parties are really happy with that
situation company a doesn't like the
variability the unpredictability in what
happens to libor and they so they don't
they can't plan for how much they have
to pay company b feels like they're
overpaying for interest they feel like
wow the people who are doing variable
interest rates they're paying a less
amount of interest every every period
and maybe they also company b also
thinks that interest rates are going to
go down or that short term or that
variable rate is going to go down libor
is going to go down so that's an even a
bigger reason why they want to become a
variable rate borrower so what they can
do and they neither of them can get out
of these lending agreements but what
they can do is agree to essentially swap
some or all of their interest rate
payments so for example they can enter
into an agreement and this would be
called an interest rate a swap where
company a
company a agrees to pay b
maybe let's let's make up a number here
seven percent
on
a notional
notional one million dollar loan so no
the one million dollars will never
change hands but company a agrees to pay
b seven percent of that notional one
million dollars or seventy thousand per
period and in return
in return company b
company b agrees to pay a a variable
rate let's say it's libor
let's say it's libor plus
one percent right over here and this
little agreement and they agree they
would agree to do this for some amount
and once again this is live war plus one
percent on a notional
on a notional
one million and that word notional just
means that that 1 million will never
change hands they're just going to
exchange the interest payments on 1
million dollars and this agreement right
over here this agreement right over here
is called an interest rate swap and i'll
leave you there in the next video we'll
actually go through the mechanics to see
that a is truly now paying is truly now
paying a fixed rate when you put in all
of their different payments into both
the swap and the lender and company b
after entering into this swap agreement
is now really paying a variable interest
rate